damning parliamentary inquiry claims the
uk government gravely mishandled its
initial response to the covert pandemic
saying thousands of deaths could have
been prevented
senior officials repeatedly avoided
every opportunity to apologize despite
the anger of those who lost their loved
ones
our government is a disgrace they didn't
listen and also they didn't think about
the lies they thought about the money
they thought about the business
contracts and they didn't close the
borders simply just letting our people
die 138 000 people today are gone
it's called coronavirus lessons learned
to date and it finds that number 10
delaying the lockdown back in march of
the 23rd in 2020 was one of the most
important public failures in the history
of the united kingdom worse still
the government's handling of the
pandemic actually led to 20 000
unnecessary deaths but a cabinet
minister unfortunately was unable to
refuse or even try and apologize for
those claims keen to start with an
apology though i would have thought oh
well no we followed the scientific
advice
we followed the scientific advice we
protected the nhs we took the decisions
based on the evidence before us but of
course we've always said with something
so unprecedented as the pandemic there
will be lessons to learn
so it's not a very gracious look there
from stephen barclay a cabinet office
minister who actually in that very
interview refused to apologize some 11
times but looking deeper into this
reporting question it's quite hefty it's
150 pages long and almost a year ago to
date was when it was first established
and when this inquiry really uh began
now they looked at many key areas
including the preparedness for pandemic
social distancing uh social care and the
impact on certain communities plus of
course the vaccines as well well it's an
incredibly traumatic and triggering day
for many for instance my best friend who
lost her mother during the pandemic to
covered and she is incredibly furious at
the government for its handling of the
pandemic but she's certainly not alone
there's thousands of bereaved families
up and down the country who are finding
this report a very difficult read indeed
so i lost my grandfather to it and his
best friend of 80 years went the next
day so my family have
had our fair share of tragedy from it
but this this isn't a personal vendetta
of you know some kind of emotional
trauma however the government want to go
around uh
you know
treating pandemics in the future i think
this is a big society wake up we've got
to stop letting these born to rule uh
straight out of private school people
run things they don't understand why is
it that we allow a prime minister with
absolutely no common sense to run a
serious pandemic absolutely everything
is down to them and when you look at at
the very beginning of this pandemic as
well our government were talking about
the idea of herd immunity now we're not
wildebeest on the plane it's not right
to let the sick and the old fall behind
and if that's the kind of attitude that
our government entered with
we cannot be surprised that so many have
died it just stands to reason that this
is exactly what they expected and they
really don't care
now a whole barrage of the criticisms
really came out in this uh report noting
um very quite big concerns including
access to ppe uh the government's much
held track and trace system which
fundamentally was flawed also suggesting
at the start of the pandemic boris
johnson said that the care homes would
not be affected now we know in hindsight
they were actually the worst affected
but the key finding really dates back to
some 20 months ago that key date of
march the 23rd when the united kingdom
entered its first
lockdown well this report says
scientists were talking some two months
prior to that about how ready the uk was
in terms of dealing with a pandemic of
this scale and actually argues that the
government acted far too slow
it is now clear that this was the wrong
policy and that it led to a higher
initial death toll than would have
resulted from a more emphatic early
policy
in a pandemic spreading rapidly and
exponentially every week counted
well boris johnson the prime minister
and his government have always
maintained throughout this pandemic the
policy is guided by the data and the
science and always maintains that it
just simply put policy into place by the
evidence that was presented to it it
also says it's sticking by its promise
of allowing a public inquiry into the
pandemic and the government's handling
of it as well but that won't come until
at least a next spring just to say
though that this very report its aim is
not to point the fingers of blame that
is a quote within this report but some
already say there is only one direction
of blame to point that finger and that
is squarely at the government i've been
saying for the last couple of years with
my group names not numbers that the
government has done an absolutely
terrible job and this is what happens
when you have leaders in charge in a
unmerited society that don't know what
they're doing
they didn't follow the science they
didn't listen to the experts and they
didn't listen to other countries that
warned them someone like boris johnson
is a prime example of what is wrong
in british politics and i just feel if
nobody stands up to point out that this
is genocide it's just something that
someone has to stand up and say because
like i say in in our culture so many
people will just take it on the chin i i
think that taking it on the chin is not
something that this you know
unprecedented situation deserves
you